hi YouTube viewers I'm looking at
permanently and I saw that there's a lot
of people who put some videos on the
YouTube about them speaking different
languages I just wanted to participate
and I want to be part of the group of
speakers of foreign languages I'm
speaking English I'm from Italy as I
told you but I'm speaking English as an
introduction I hope because it's a most
common language I hope that everybody
understands its introduction and so I'm
going to make more or less a list of my
languages and then I'm going to speak
some phrases even if it's not you know
it's like I'm trying to demonstrate that
I can speak some of the languages but
it's not easy you know so it's going to
be a ten minute video moralist and hope
I'm not going to bore you the first line
the first language is English second
language is Italian and Lamia in
Burgundy no no Pato Escala in italiano
sono di roma Peggy Vespa avocados I'm no
Italian the third language can be French
first remove that she issued an
ultimatum to apostasia appear
Christmas or via de Chivo the dedicatory
open open versus Kenya a prayer
conservatory Xiao Feng Erica pagan
religion acutally do a metal difficult
focus palette by reporting the pleasure
of a peak till then a preventive of the
same a great unit of the Austrian
physician fidgety palaces has an
enormous to the beautiful palette Omaima
more valuable fish pass along to radical
in of the column of a foreign knockoff
opinion of the scope of a few trees so
the cottage in on table
the fourth one is gave East German
nucleus the door jam is falling a finite
range Baba is poof Eliza stuff yeah miss
interested then is aptoide Java
Galera a majority about the fact Eastman
others part of in management Fighting
Championships
following a fine establish the problems
when is the water pepper slice Mesa by
Spicer meeting English to demolish
crisis meeting of English our normal
Eliza venison I'm an innovation open
this paper is spices finish raffle and
his movie Skytop material storage for
files would fall and the fourth line is
no the fifth climate is going to be
Spanish responding estamos in Spanish I
was a master onigiri as possible Colonel
Wharton the tenth row mesmo marsala
italiano SEO experience phenomenal Luna
go desk a a quien cada una salami
rowspan Yoli Makaton bueno si si habla
espanol con las personas hurry Ontario's
respond
understand in espanol paranormal meant a
scooch amo mucho Katahdin además la la
niñas alle sammen Kidada a seguro sagaie
Kita's quadroon Erica Don también fue
grace pero ya suficiente respond yo creo
en lo aprendido que saber polenta's
gusta como el mismo horse Oh Y
pero ahora diferencia de vos a
fundamental despues mucho más fácil
aromatic adido si esto no es un problema
que aprender español es un problema e
the flames can be taught a lower-end a
los Cragen along Nemer Hoskote Omar de
que dice a case a creek mo mo volcanoes
Craig about explain it Mahakali en el
lenders o Sigmund Englanders squag
strangly on tides in it angles equated
meme artists come back liquor and ankle
a kiss a comeback like or anything else
to be seen
I'll set the elves at the unit neighbors
and come back house you have in my leg
back a gun book laser was on the program
and and the nails and and dads and he'll
collect and the self language gonna be
finished
your elk of the fearsome Ross ruff
you madman
expect a Vista so anxious for insular
consult exert the Union English nor
spoken of millionaires and characters
governing Boucherie kept the authorship
of lamb Alaska of you are parallel they
are you know they are therefore Zhen hai
aur Patthar share Koshka and don't
compromise okay okay better from last
October so you're so light on your
bottle communist-era abnormal naturally
please I have a letter from cerebral
anger coming your sugar often Mariota
transfer of Protestant and the eighth
time is going to be Russian
you have no rupiah in the new career new
to Naga village Podolski no well the
Russian language I get I get start again
I learned it for three years I ran out a
kind of character but starting again in
a couple of weeks and hopefully it's
going to get better so I just hopefully
you enjoy the video and we'll see you
sometime soon ciao